[Music]
hashtag welcome to us BTS is trending
worldwide and that's because the kpop
boy band turned crossover pop phenomenon
have touched down in Los Angeles that's
right
fans not only showered them with love
they just about lost it and I was there
for all the fandemonium
[Music]
it was BTS mania outside of LAX this
morning fans lined up all morning long
just to catch a glimpse of the global
pop sensations
[Applause]
why do you love BTS so much like what's
so great about can't believe they've
gone this far how excited are you guys
to see them today I just stayed up all
night and it was crazy we all stayed up
people our height I love you guys so
much I'm still proud of you guys to love
you BTS insane right the boys are in
town for a major performance at this
weekend American Music Awards while
they're here they're also gonna plan to
hit Jay Jimmy Kimmel Live lln and The
Late Late Show with James Corden oh and
also the daily Denny that's right it's
me plus BTS behind the scenes at their
AMA rehearsal I sit down with them
tomorrow so head over to the community
tab and leave your questions for the
boys there until then make sure you guys
are subscribed to our Channel and are
getting these notifications because it
is BTS week and you don't want to miss
out cannot wait
you